à chacun ses priorités Moscou a libéré
215 prisonniers Kiev seulement 55 dont
Victor metzuk un homme d'affaires russe
intime de Poutine après les avoir
accusés d'être des nazis le président
russe devra peut-être désormais
expliquer pourquoi il en a libéré autant
en échange du père de sa filleule et de
quelques autres cet échange a vécu comme
une victoire dans la capitale
ukrainienne
ce n'est pas une perte d'échanger mais
devait tchouc contre de vrais guerriers
toutes les enquêtes nécessaires ont été
faites conformément à la loi l'Ukraine a
obtenu de lui tout ce qui était
nécessaire pour établir la vérité sur
ses activités criminelles parmi les 215
personnes libérées par Moscou 188 font
partie de ceux qui ont défendu la série
azousta la Mario Paul symbole de la
résistance ukrainienne ils avaient été
contraints de se rendre en mai dernier
après trois mois d'intens combat ces
hommes sont considérés comme des héros
par Kiev les négociations ont été
difficiles pour le sort réserver à 5
commandes en militaires Ukrainiens eux
aussi retenu prisonniers ils ont
finalement été transférés en Turquie où
il resteront jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
selon la corne négocié avec le président
turc redchepta hyperdoan un autre pays
l'Arabie Saoudite qui vient pourtant de
voter en faveur d'une résolution pour
condamner l'invasion russe a également
joué les médiateurs l'accord conclu par
Riad a permis à 10 prisonniers étrangers
détenus par des forces pro russes d'être
lâcher mais pas n'importe où ils ont été
transférés à Riad la capitale saoudienne
il s'agit de cinq britanniques deux
Américains un Marocain un Suédois et un
Croate la Maison Blanche à remercier le
prince héritier Mohamed Ben Salman sur
Twitter celui-là même qu'elle promettait
de traiter en Paris il y a moins de 2
ans parmi les prisonniers étrangers
libérés certains comme le Marocain
Brahim Sadoun avait été condamné à mort
sado n'avait participé au combat dans
l'armée ukrainienne avant d'être capturé
à deniers tous devraient regagner
rapidement leur pays respectifs